je vais aller au niveau de la cellule de
haut niveau moléculaire
et étudié l'adn de mes patients qui a un
retard du développement psychomoteur
[Musique]
j'avais des membres de ma famille qui
avait fait des études scientifiques
mais depuis que j'étais petit j'étais
curieuse j'aimerais j'aimais les
matières comme la chimie la biologie et
j'étais surtout fasciné par les cellules
adn quand j'ai terminé la médecine j'ai
été épaté par la structure les
structures moléculaires alors c'est où
j'ai préféré de faire la génétique
humaine
la recherche porte sur les amplis
l'identification des anomalies
génétiques causant des troubles du
développement psychomoteur chez des
enfants et on va faire ce diagnostic en
utilisant
l'utilisation de logiciels de
reconnaissance faciale et des techniques
de séquençage de l'adn je suis allé
rechercher les erreurs dans l'adn de mes
patients et j'en ai trouvé j'ai remarqué
que ces patients ils avaient une valeur
l'aspect de leur de leurs visages
étaient parfois particuliers il ya des
logiciels qui de reconnaissance faciale
qui existent et qu'ils analysent
l'aspect du visage de ces patients par
exemple la trisomie 21
il ya des syndromes comme le syndrome de
williams l'x fragile
mais les logiciels existants et ils ont
été créés la plupart du temps sur base
de données des patients d'origine
européenne asiatique ont valeur et d
améliorer leurs algorithmes en
additionnant des images de nos patients
d'origine africaine mais aussi on va
faire des tests de laboratoire
pour pro pour voir si vraiment le
patient à la maladie qui a été suggéré
par le zii le logiciel de reconnaissance
faciale
puis aller à travailler dans un hôpital
de district y avait des enfants qui
avaient des troubles du développement
psychomoteur mais quand je les regardais
je trouvais qu'il avait un aspect du
visage un peu spécifiques et à ce moment
là il y avait aucun généticien alors je
me demandais sama j'étais curieuse de
savoir ce que ses enfants
avaient et c'est pour ça que j'ai été
poussé à faire la génétique
mon projet va permettre de former des
médecins situés dans des hôpitaux de
district à utiliser ce logiciel de
reconnaissance faciale nécessaire pour
le diagnostic de ces maladies pour les
parents de connaître la cause de la
maladie de leur enfant et par exemple si
c'est une maladie qui se trouve dans la
famille pouvoir conseiller les parents
[Musique]
le fait que je suis une femme
scientifique c'est pour encourager les
autres femmes les autres jeunes filles
qui peuvent
aspirer à des carrières scientifiques
pour pas avoir peur il faut aller en
avant même s'il ya beaucoup de
problèmes d'obstacles mais chacun sait
chaque personne qui fait sa propre
carrière
[Musique]